joining us with more reaction to my
opening monologue from the hill Joe
Concha Fox News national security
analyst former deputy assistant to the
president dr. Sebastian corker dr. Gorka
the Justice Department now investigating
Comey
criminal referrals on every top figure
Lynch on Hillary herself on Comey on
McCabe unstruck on page then the IG
referral criminal referral as it relates
to McCabe all that we've talked about is
now happening everything the meetings
talked about has been wrong yes
absolutely for the last 14 months let's
just tie it all together the jigsaw
puzzle must be made into a full picture
we now know Andy McCarthy's hypothesis
is absolutely sound the work of Sarah
Cara John Solomon our own Fox Catherine
Herridge it is clear the Obama
administration wanted Hillary to win she
was protected by the highest echelons of
the DOJ FBI why because her felonious
use of a private server to send
classified information on implicated the
president himself we know President
Obama under a pseudonym contacted her
and sent sensitive information on that
private home-brew server which meant if
she was prosecuted guess who has to be
prosecuted as well President Obama that
is why they perverted the course of
justice and everything should be renamed
not FISA gait not surveillance gait
it must be renamed tonight Sean Obama
gait deep state gait Obama gait whatever
you want
Joe you follow the media you follow
their coverage I'm not ever expecting a
retraction and apology but the the level
of breathless hysteria and reporting
especially on the cable networks not Fox
and in The Washington Post in The New
York Times
anonymous sources fake news debunk
stories conspiracy theories this now
represents news in America the New York
Times Sean the biggest complaint among
readers and this has been going on for
years and years is the use of anonymous
sources the utter reliance on them
obviously we don't know what motive
those sources have usually it's probably
a nefarious one if they want to get
these things out they're not just
innocent whistleblowers they're looking
to push a narrative to hurt people in
positions of power and we've seen that
over and over again
so look Devin Nunez who is obviously the
head of the Intelligence Committee in
the house he has been dismissed by the
media for the most part he's been called
the Lackey and then you look at the
other side his counterpart Adam Schiff
you know how many interviews Adam Schiff
has done and I'm not talking print
interviews or online I'm talking
television brought down menus he's done
since the president took office 240 so
if you need to know if the media is
picking a side they're giving Adam
Schiff a huge stage on an almost daily
basis while Nunez is seen as well that's
the guy who's just trying to support
Trump trying to push the false narrative
I think that's all the evidence you need
Shawn you know it is interesting dr.
korkor and there you mentioned there's a
group of us you're included in that
group and Sarah and Greg and Larry and I
can't mention everybody and the bottom
line is this is the biggest abuse of
power we've ever seen in this country's
history the biggest corruption case in
history I've never seen you know
unmasking leaking surveillance FISA
abuse exonerations before investigations
felonies just not even be impressive
every one of these stories is
unbelievable we've we've had problems
you've had scandals in the past you go
back to the 60s and 70s especially
there's a reason we have the church and
pike commissions we had COINTELPRO which
was a scandal for the FBI but guess what
Shawn in almost every case it was a it
was the good guys overstepping the mark
there were bad people there were
radicals they were asked this they were
terrorists like the Weathermen
underground and they were overzealous in
the application of intelligence tools
Shawn in this case it's not going after
bad guys it's going after your Democrat
your opponent in a democratic election
it's going after somebody you
politically disagree with and using the
internalizing and political differences
right and that
that's a massive scandal for the
Republic last word Joe well we talked
about the bias of omission a lot Sean
that's the worst kind of bias you could
have and you talked before about not
covering some of the more positive
aspects of what this administration is
accomplishing and look I'm not going to
put that out there some sort of
cheerleader I look at pure research
right after the election and here's what
they said the top three issues that
voters voted on 84 percent said the
economy and jobs 80% terrorism Isis in
this case obviously 75 percent foreign
policy so we look at those three issues
and foreign policy obviously we have to
look at North Korea in those regards
the president is doing quite well on the
issues that mattered most of people yet
those are the issues that get the least
reporting by our media because we're
looking too much at Russia and stormy
Daniels and things that people don't
care about as much as our media in the
bubble thinks they do alright guys thank
you both for being with